moving on
our main story tonight concerns
healthcare the field responsible for
repairing organs
treating cancer and removing foreign
objects from rectums which have recently
included
a plastic turtle a fork six magic
markers
and a cat toy bell which credit where
it's due is the most promising
advancement in cat hiding places since
under the dresser access to healthcare
is a big
problem in america and one of the key
reasons is that health insurance
is often linked to employment why is
that the case well
because we do it wrong there is a right
way to do it
but we don't do it that way we do it the
wrong way
and this is a particular problem at the
moment because employment is still down
7.6 million jobs
from its pre-pandemic level all of which
means that many are struggling to find
healthcare coverage right now so
they might be intrigued if they stumble
on an ad like this
my health care costs were gonna double
this year doubled
doubled it was down to health care or my
student loans
i found a better way it's neighbors
helping neighbors liberty
health share it's freedom from insurance
at liberty health share we support each
other and keep health costs down we're
changing the way
you're paying for health care this is
the way it should be
we're all in this together together well
hold on
because i'm not sure how together you
all are what i saw there was a bunch of
people together with
warm lens flares and then one weird
older man very much
on his own in black and white he's in a
slightly different thing and we're not
going to say why but on some level
i think we all know that ad is for
something called a health care
sharing ministry and if you haven't
heard of them before you may have come
across one and not even realized it
because they have been growing fast in
the us and the key phrase in that ad is
freedom from insurance because the most
important thing to know about health
care sharing ministries or
hcsms isn't just that they can be
cheaper than health insurance
which they can is that they are also not
health insurance
generally they are non-profits where
people who share religious beliefs
usually christianity agree to help cover
each other's medical bills
here is a heartwarming story about what
one of them looks like in practice
we're praying for a young lady named
kimberly bob stedman and his family are
praying for someone they've never met
she had a shunt installed in her brain
they've also prepared a card with a
check
for 561 dollars to bear
her burden by sending them some money a
scene like this
plays out here once a month it does take
a measure of faith to do it
we are sharing this is so different than
what we're used to in our society
he's right people actually looking out
for each other
does sound better than our current
system which is get sick
have insurance decline coverage and then
hope debra messing retweets your
gofundme
that's great deborah but did you donate
did you
did you debra and it does feel more
personal sending 500
a month to a stranger in need than to a
company that sounds like someone made up
a word after getting a shitty scrabble
hand
perhaps that is why the local news team
who covered that story
seemed so moved after it ended i mean
can you imagine being that person and
getting the check
you know not knowing that someone was
going to help you and then suddenly you
have all this help
right it's all about faith isn't it
faith that it's going to get paid faith
in god and it's just amazing
it's incredible yeah of course they're
into this
faith strangers coming together throw in
a runaway
dog who found his owner in the hospital
even though he'd never been to the
hospital
and you've got yourself a schedule one
local news thirst trap
and hcsms are definitely an alternative
but
as you've probably guessed because
you're learning about them on this show
and not
what if john oliver was somehow less
angry less english and had jack ryan
money
there are also some significant
drawbacks which
depending on the company in question can
range from the disquieting
to the disqualifying so tonight let's
talk about
healthcare sharing ministries what they
are what they do and more importantly
what they don't do and the first thing
to know is hcsms have actually existed
in the united states for decades
traditionally
serving small insular communities like
mennonites and the amish however
the 2010 affordable care act included a
loophole that exempted
uninsured people from paying the tax
penalty if
they were a member of an hcsm and that
was clearly immediately appealing to
anyone who wanted to opt out of
obamacare in fact
some htsms like liberty healthcare one
of the biggest ministries
have specifically targeted a
conservative audience
liberty has run ads on the blaze and
also sponsored cpac
in fact remember that famous moment when
trump molested the flag
the liberty logo was an eyewitness to
that crime
and liberty even made its sales pitch
directly to the cpac audience during
panels like this one
if you want the government to take care
of you and you think they do a great job
doing it
health sharing is not for you if you
want to stick it to them
sign up for liberty healthcare
[Applause]
okay on a list of the worst sounds known
to man
self-satisfied cpac laughter has to be
right at the top beat only by
weeping kitten and mother's orgasm now
that affordable care act loophole did
try to put some limits in place to keep
things from getting out of hand it
stated that your ministry or crucially
a predecessor of it had to have been in
continuous existence
since 1999 but unfortunately that
predecessor detail
left room for exploitation because new
ministries simply started affiliating
themselves
with previously existing churches take
one called trinity health share it was
founded in 2018 which is and this is
true
after 1999 but it argued that it's still
qualified because
it derived its existence from the
baptist church which has been in
existence and continually sharing
since the 1600s which is obvious
it's like me claiming that this show has
been around for 13 billion years
because the big bang was also a bright
expanse containing extremely dense
material
that's just not how anything works so a
loophole that was intended to be small
got pretty big and even bigger once
obamacare's individual mandate
stopped being enforced during the trump
years and the result of all of this was
that the popularity of these ministries
exploded from an estimated 200 000
members a decade ago
to more than a million today and while
hesms will insist
that they make it abundantly clear that
they are not health insurance
many do seem to go out of their way to
make themselves appear
as insurance-like as possible for start
they're sometimes sold through insurance
brokers alongside
actual insurance plans and while the
obamacare marketplace
offers plans in four metal categories
bronze silver
gold and platinum a company called altoa
offered plans in gold
silver bronze and copper rebranding them
last year to
diamond emerald sapphire and ruby
although it is still
pretty clear what they're trying to do
there very much blur the line while also
throwing some extremely unfair shade at
ruby the objective goat of the cardinal
gems
she's red known for her flaws and
responsible for the most iconic slippers
in the history of cinema
eat your hearts out sapphire and
emeralds because you could literally
never but while these hcsms may have the
optics
of insurance there are some very
important differences
for start they don't have to abide by
laws governing insurance products
meaning there is nothing stopping them
from placing restrictions on coverage
for pre-existing conditions
which is exactly what they do and not
only that
many won't cover services considered
essential under the aca like
treatment for substance abuse or mental
health care in fact
ultra excludes those and also treatment
for obesity
or autism and samaritan's classic plan
has a list of non-qualified items
including routine
maintenance stabilized preventive and
wellness care
that is everything from regular checkups
to vaccinations
and even for eligible expenses the most
that can be shared for a given need
is 250 thousand dollars which probably
explains their full name
samaritan not the good one though just a
random samaritan who might well leave
you to die in the middle of an abandoned
road
and we haven't even gotten to one of the
biggest excuses htsms can use
to deny coverage and that is morality
because
that means that you can be denied
coverage for basically
anything this is a program of the
christian care
ministry and people who smoke or
same-sex couples
need not apply the program also won't
pay for illnesses related to alcohol
abortion or other lifestyle related
choices
i need to know that i'm not going to be
paying for someone else who's decided to
sit on the couch and eat bonbons all day
wow that is harsh
but i will say that judgmental tone is
very much in line with how these
ministries operate
do people really deserve healthcare
coverage if they eat junk food or don't
exercise or are gay
just fix it eat a carrot go for a run
rub your penis or vagina on someone
else's vagina or penis respectively
it's really not difficult and this is a
pattern across
hcsm's liberty's materials say an
applicant must comply
with a christian lifestyle and among the
exclusions on samaritan's classic
program
you'll find that they might pay for
treatment for an std but
not if it was contracted by sex outside
of marriage and
that the member has to explain how the
disease was contracted
presumably the hotter the story the more
money you get for ointments
vanilla missionary isn't going to
get covered here bud you better have
gotten gonorrhea from an earlobe if you
want samaritan's attention
but sweeping moral judgment isn't the
only leeway that these organizations
have
because they are voluntary associations
you have
no guarantee that your bills will get
paid although to hear a founder of
liberty health share
tell it you've really got nothing to
worry about there just listen to him
reassure people in a video on their
website titled will my bills
be paid we've had a successful history
of sharing medical bills 100 for every
eligible need ever submitted so it
doesn't depend
upon a written contract where we can sue
each other
if someone doesn't send their share
amount it's really a contract
written on our hearts all right
it's a contract written on your heart
figuratively of course because literally
it's not a contract and as for his claim
there that liberty
successfully shared a hundred percent of
medical bills for
every eligible need given as we've
discussed
they can deem any need ineligible for
any reason that phrase is essentially as
meaningless as their cardiac
non-contract
and on top of all of this there is the
practical matter of how
exactly you pay for your care as a
member the hsn process typically is
you're told to present yourself as
uninsured then
when you get your bill the expectation
is that you bargain down the cost of
your care as much as you can
then pay the bill yourself then submit
your bills
to the ministry for reimbursement and if
you have ever waited for your friends to
venmo you after paying for dinner
you know that the reimbursement process
can go very wrong
participants in liberty you know the one
with the heart contract
have found payments can be slow to
non-existent
in the past three years tiffany schultz
with the wisconsin better business
bureau says the bbb
has taken more than 500 complaints about
liberty health share
many with similar stories one claiming
90 thousand in outstanding medical bills
that were pre-approved
either the consumer is out the money and
hasn't been reimbursed
or they're ending up going to
collections that's not great
and while liberty claims that 2019 was a
particularly difficult year and they are
proud of the improvements they've made
since then it is worth noting that
liberty's members
still seem pretty active on the better
business bureau website where they've
logged
304 complaints in the last 12 months
which is
a lot especially when you consider that
cigna a massive insurer
has just half that amount while having
15 times the members
and imagine having more people complain
about you
than about cigna a company whose logo
is a cartoon man standing in a field as
his head explodes from dealing with
their customer service
and unfortunately in most states a
complaint to the better business bureau
is basically all the recourse you have
and these ministries have worked
very hard to keep accountability at bay
successfully lobbying for so-called
safe harbor laws in more than 30 states
ensuring that they can operate
safely outside of insurance regulations
and to see just how much you can get
away with it's worth looking at a
company called
alera which has been heavily involved
with a number of health sharing
ministries over the years
first one called unity then one called
trinity which now goes by
charity although those names sound less
like healthcare organizations are more
like
characters in a religious themed captain
planet knock-off
when their powers combine they get
cancelled after two
episodes alira presents itself as merely
an administrator
for hcsms but it is intricately
connected
to the ones that it works with and very
much by design
just six weeks after trinity was
incorporated it signed a deal with alera
stipulating that alira would have
exclusive ownership rights to the
membership roster and
was the sole party developing and
marketing the plans including
the htsm component so aller's
relationship with trinity
is basically this guy's relationship to
his alien costume
he can claim he isn't technically the
costume
and that's true but the costume doesn't
really do anything without him
and customers in multiple states have
claimed that elira and its ministries
have been ruthless in denying coverage
wielding morality clauses hard when one
member was attacked and knocked
unconscious outside a bar
and taken to the hospital with serious
injuries including a skull fracture
cervical spine fracture and intercranial
bleeding
alira denied her claims stating her
injuries were
self-inflicted and citing their
guidelines including the line
follow spiritual teachings on the use or
abuse of
alcohol which i'm pretty sure is the
benevolent advice jesus himself would
have given under the circumstances
and incredibly that's not even the worst
story of a rejected claim involving a
lira
ten-year-old lola gray seegers is
healthy just four months after brain
surgery on september 11 she was rushed
from the local er in greene county by
ambulance to children's health care
scottish right
where doctors removed a softball sized
brain tumor it was
just amazing the care but last week came
the bill from their health plan alera
companies
325 thousand 624.
alera says children's is out of network
and won't pay the 325
thousand dollar bill we had a
life-threatening emergency
they failed us and her
holy they were denied reimbursement
for a child who had a softball-sized
tumor removed from her brain which is
incidentally
exactly the kind of immoral behavior i'd
expect sharing ministries to classify
as disqualifying now alira
claims that that family's issues were
ultimately resolved but only after
that story was featured on the news and
it shows just how little recourse you
have
that if you don't have a child that you
can get onto tv to shame the company
into action
you could be out of luck and look
traditional insurance companies
also have their share of horror stories
when it comes to denial of coverage
but there are important differences here
not just in the level of protection that
you have when that happens but
in the degree of financial
accountability because
while the aca requires actual health
insurance to spend
no more than 20 of money on
administrative costs therefore
leaving at least 80 percent for care
there is
no such requirement for hcsms and you
can probably tell
where this is going because
investigations have found that out of
every hundred dollars
a trinity member paid in premiums only
went towards paying medical expenses
with the rest being kicked up to a lira
and paying out 16 of the money that you
take in for coverage
is a lot different than paying out 80
because 80
makes you think wait why exactly do we
have insurance companies
whereas 16 makes you think is a crime
happening to me right now and if so
why does everyone seem okay with it and
when a local news reporter caught up
with the head of elira to ask her
about his reluctance to pay out claims
her response
was not particularly reassuring do you
have any apologies
to the members who believe their claims
ought to be played and they're not paid
we're not a health care sharing ministry
mr strickland
we only administer on behalf of the
ministries
i can't help you any further i need to
get out of town okay
it is never a good sign when a ceo has
to end an interview like that
as i've said before our company has
never done anything illegal
now have you seen a man in a blue fedora
he's supposed to give me a new identity
as i get pulled into a helicopter that's
already taking off
tell my daughter i loved her and my
husband i didn't i'm
out now i should say other sharing
ministries have tried to distance
themselves from illyria claiming that
this sort of deception is not part of
legitimate authentic
healthcare sharing ministries and alira
is definitely bad
but one thing insurance commissioners
have repeatedly told us in researching
this piece
is how little transparency there is into
how these ministries operate
and just how weary they think people
should be
of all of them and look broadly we
have to do more in this country to
reduce the cost of healthcare personally
i'd argue switching to a single-payer
system would remove a lot of these
problems instantly but that
clearly isn't happening anytime soon so
in the meantime i do get the appeal
of lower-cost health insurance the
problem is this
isn't that it's not insurance at all
and states need at the very least to
pass laws to make sure
that people know what they're getting
into with hcsms and
to force them to allocate funds properly
the problem is
some are going in the opposite direction
take florida
in 2018 after intense lobbying it
loosened its restrictions on hsms even
further
going from requiring that participants
be members of the same religion to
merely requiring that they
share a common set of ethical or
religious beliefs
and that could be basically anything at
this point
the barter entry is so low just about
anyone can become an hcsm
and the reason i know that is this
anyone did
you may remember back in 2015 we founded
a church
our lady of perpetual exemption to
demonstrate that tax exemptions for
churches
enabled some of them to do terrible
things well just three months ago we
officially founded a spin-off church
called
our lady of perpetual health and we
founded it where else
but florida and i'm happy to tell you
that church now has its own health care
sharing ministry
johnny care and the whole thing was
scarily easy to do
so without further ado please join me
my most blessed congregants at church
and you know i couldn't run an
organization as important
as this ministry all by myself so please
welcome live
from johnny care headquarters in sunny
florida the felicity huffman
to my william h macy my dear wife and
business partner
wanda joe praise me to you my wonder
praise be to you my john and praise be
to florida
that blessed state where minimally
regulated insurance knockoffs go to be
born
and retired people go to die amen to
that i have heard the word of the lord
my john oh and what did it say my wonder
it said thou must free thyself like a
gazelle from the hand of the hunter
from the overreaching grasp of
government healthcare
stick it to him stick it to him
now wanda we're running the ministry as
a church even though in florida we
actually don't have to be
amen praise florida but we do need to
fulfill the requirement
that our ministry provide for the
financial or medical needs of a
participant
through contributions from other
participants the good news is
we have done that through our special
johnny care first
aid kit containing not one not two
but three band-aids it screams the
cheapest
option that we could find and you know
what rwanda what my john
it was now why three band-aids
because we know that in life sometimes
accidents happen
but if they happen more than three times
it just stops being our problem
and let me be clear when you sign up for
membership you're not paying for your
own first aid kit you're paying for
someone else's
and they are paying for yours and that
gives you
freedom from insurance and us freedom
from responsibility
and beyond that it's a very simple
system if you need medical care you go
to the doctor
you receive it you request a bill and
then you pay that bill
on your own leave us out of it
oh yeah because if you submit that bill
to us we're gonna reject it
from his lips to god's bigger lips in
the sky
testify either because you engaged in
the sin of fornication beyond the bonds
of matrimony
you're whoring little skis or you spent
the day eating bon bons on the couch
instead of going to the gym
or masturbate it ever whatever it is
we're going to reject it and it's as
easy as that
no deductibles no claims and no
contracts except
for the one written on our hearts
now you can become a member of our
johnny care ministry for just 1.99
and we're limiting membership to 5 000
of you in florida not because we have to
but because that is the number of first
aid kits that we've bought so go to
freedomfromhealthcare.org and see if you
qualify to send us money
and get almost nothing in return as
close to nothing as we could get away
with
and to be clear we should not be able to
get away with any of this
thank you to wanda joe who if history is
any indication
will disappear for three years and
ultimately resurfacing the canadian
mohegan sun
answering to deb i just love you so much
my wanda oh and i love you
so much my john visit
freedomfromhealthcare.org to learn how
you can
stick it to him stick it to him
that's our show thank you so much for
watching good night
you